こんにちは、スティーブ・カウフマン今日
は
、私がいつも受ける非常に重要な質問であると思うことについて話したいと思います。
それは、言語を学ぶのにどれくらいの時間がかかる
かという
ことです。 言語習得の3つの段階になるので、
言語習得のその段階から始めましょう。
言語習得の
4つの段階をグーグルで
検索すると
、最初に知っている言語生成の段階について話し
ます。
私にとって言語
習得は言語生産に関するものではなく
、最初は
どのように言語を習得するかについての短い文章
です。特に
この過去3〜4
か月のアラビア語とペルシャ語での経験に
基づいて、
来年のトルコ語を考えてみましょう。あなたが知っている言語をすべて習得
するための私の段階は、トルコ語にどれくらいかかると思い
ますか。
実は
かなり昔に巻いた記事を調べて、最近
ブログに載せ直し
ました。最初の段階での言語習得の3つの段階について話し
ます。これには
60〜90時間かかります。  1日1時間に3か月と呼びます。
もちろん、これは言語によって異なり
ますが、7〜8年前の記事
で、
ペルシア語とアラビア語で経験したことを正確に説明しました。
この記事を最初に書いたときは知らなかった簡単な話を何度も何度も聞く必要があります。少なくとも、ポーランド語と純粋な勉強をしているとき
に気付いた視点の話は、多くの話を知りませんでした。
ポーランド語ドットPLはこれらを非常に
効果的に使用します私はAJ
ホーグがこれを英語で行うことを
発見しましたそして私
はあなたに関係する人々の
何人かがそれがTPRS教育能力と呼ばれるものを知っていることを発見しまし
た 読書と
ストーリーテリングもこの
テクニックを使用しています。リンクには60のストーリーがあります。
これは、この観点のストーリーテリングテクニックのほんの一例です
が
、これらを何
度も聞いてリンクで
確認し、言葉を確認することで、私は理解しました。
言語のことなので、私はこれを
90時間から100時間と呼びます。私はそれ
を
あなたが達成しなければならないすべての言語に接続して呼びます。それで私は
今ペルシア語の感覚を持って
います。
ペルシア語の場合、
アラビア語と組み合わせても3か月間
、言語とつながることができました。
実際にいくつかのことが言え
ます。言語がどのように機能するかはある程度わかっています
が、
文法の細かい点はアラビア語に気づいていません。
文法がより複雑であるか、少なくとも
私がインドヨーロッパ言語の話者として慣れているものとは異なるため、アラビア語ははるかに困難です。
ライティングシステムはmです。 鉱石が難しく
、アラビア語のスクリプトとアラビア語で接続する
ように
なりました。ペルシャ語に到達するまでに読みやすくなった
ので、言語によっては
長くなる可能性がありますが、最初の段階は
言語との接続です。
多くのリスニングとリーディングを通じて行われ
、理想的に
は、言語の最も一般的な動詞が
何度も使用され、
非常に一般的な結合と接続する
単語やフレーズが何度も使用される場所をリンクする多くのストーリーがあります。
ですから
、私
が週に1回、アラビア語とバージョンのそれぞれで講師を務めることを個人的に楽しんだとき、あなたは自然に言語を吸収
しますが、それは便利だと思いますが、
条件ではありません。
したがって
、1日3か月の時間に基づいて
、言語がどれほど似ているか、および書記体系が2番目に精通しているものにどれほど似ているかに応じて、長くなる可能性があり
ます。
私がここでも言語に慣れると呼んでいるステージは、
主に
入力ベースです。私の経験では、十分
な語彙があれば
、理解度が高いかどうかを理解できれば
、出力は
あなたのように来るからです。 より多くの機会があるか
、話す機会が増えると、
話す能力が向上し
ますが、この受動的な知識を活性化
して、習得したこの語彙を理解します。
第2段階では
、ペルシャ語とアラビア語のように続ける
ことができます。 私の多くの話を聞き続けています
実際、私は
今でもロシア語とウクライナ語で
それをやっていて、
構造とケースの
終わりと動きの語彙とこの種のものをよりよく理解するためにしています
が、私は拡大する必要があります 私の語彙
を拡張する必要がありますあなたは
私が理解していることを理解し
ていることを知ってい
ます
al-jazeeraのアラビア語で、40〜50％の
未知の単語があり、快適ではありません
。実際
、第1段階が3か月の場合、第1段階の2倍の長さの第2段階では、理想的に読んだり聞いたりするのは困難です。
第2段階
は6か月になる可能性があり、ここで
は会話を探すのが理想的です。
ある程度ポッドキャストは会話です
が、
私が聞いているポッドキャストの多くには、特別な語彙がたくさんあります。
それを続けていくと、最終的にはその
語彙を習得します。たとえば、政治や
経済学な
ので、これらのテキスト
は私にとってより快適になり
ますが、中級レベルのコンテンツを見つけることができれば、アラビア語で感じました。
名詞は繰り返さ
れますが、より頻繁に繰り返される語彙ほど頻繁には繰り返されませんが
、ある意味では
、表現する能力にとってより重要
です。 理想的には
、リンクポッドキャストをもう一度開始
して、2
人がイタリア語、フランス語、または日本語
で話し合って、自然な会話ができるようにします
が、最初に話し、
次に書かれたものではなく
、 次に読んで、これが
非常に活発になるようにします。
会話を盗聴し
ているのは興味深いことですが、リンクの場合は
、トランスクリプトを読んで
単語を保存し、しばらくすると、同じ
2人が話している場合は
日常生活や
興味のあることについてお互いに多くの語彙
が私が中国語でとても楽しんだ別のことを繰り返すでしょう
そして
ある程度ロシア語でこれのいくつかを見つけました
あなたは私に興味のある主題に関する本を知っ
ています ノンフィクションこれは
通常、文学の
ノンフィクションの
歴史地理学よりも簡単ですが、語彙が単純化され
ているため、
私が直面していない言語で快適さのレベルを上げています あなたは50％の未知の単語を知っている
ので、
この種の中間レベルの
資料を見つけて、
徐々に本物の本物の資料
に移行することができれば
、私は韓国語でやることを自分自身に押し付け、
ルーマニア語でやることを自分自身に押し付けました。
ギリシャ語とアラビア語でやるのですが、彼は
私には少し難しすぎたので、私は
その快適さのレベルに到達していませんでしたが、
理想的に
は、もはや単純ではない多くの物語の素材で作業するのに6か月かかるでしょ
うが、それは完全ではありません
本格的な本物の素材、または
単に本物の素材を掘り下げて、
そこに行きたいと思っていることを知っているあなたはそれに興味があります
未知の言葉がたくさんありますあなたはこれらの言葉を保存し
ますあなたはオーディオを聞いて
徐々にあなたは より快適になります
が、この時期に
言語に慣れ
て、私の意見ではさらに6
か月になるので、今では9か月になります。3
か月は主に多くの
ストーリーがあります。  sそれから4〜9か月目は、
中間資料または興味深い
本物の資料のいずれかに
なり、この段階で言語の快適さを高めることができます。
通常
、私
は週に2回行くこともあるので、家庭教師とのやり取りを増やします。
今
、私は実際に
面白いことについて話すことができる十分な語彙を習得し始めています、そして
もちろんリンクで私
は私が苦労した単語やフレーズで家庭教師からレポートを受け取ります
そしてそれから私はこれらをコンテンツとして勉強し
ます 幸運なことに、先生は私
にも聞くためのオーディオファイルをくれます。それで
、私たちが9か月になり、次の
段階になり
ます。完璧ではないので、私は単に絶え間ない改善と呼びますが、あなた
は今
、ほとんど聞くことができる言語で十分に快適です。
興味のあるもの、または興味のあるものを読ん
で、言語の側面に注意を払うために語彙を習得し続け、したがって
改善し続け、これ
あなたがその言語で過ごす時間がある限り続けること
ができますそして私はあなたが今立ち上げられた言語
で快適な快適さの言い換えればそのレベルを達成し
たらあなたが今その言語で好きなだけ行くことができる
と思います
文法については大丈夫です
先日私たちが
日本語で教えることについて話し合ったような発音の細かい点について
私がアラビア語を始めたときあなたが知っていることは
さまざまな種類のアラビア語の動詞
とあらゆる言語についてのあらゆる種類の複雑な説明がありました
私がトルコ語で始めた場合、これを見つけるでしょ
うトルコ語の文法について多くの説明があります
トルコ語の発音
これらの優れた
アジア人のほとんどは、学習者が何かを説明しているため、
他の何よりも威圧的である
ため非常に困難です
まだ経験がない
ので
、学習者に言語を体験させて、
特定のことに気づかせたり、
特定の薄さに気づかなかったりする方がはるかに良いと思います gsそして、学習者
がアラビア語の文法のある側面に興味があるとき、
またはピッチに興味がある場合
はピッチに興味があるとき、彼らは
入ってそれを読むことができます、そしてそれは
彼らがすでにいくつか持っている何かを扱っていることを知っているでしょう 言語に精通している
が、それはある種の流暢さへの主な道ではない
流暢さへの主な道
は言語
をあなたに取り入れることであり、それは
私の3つの段階のどこにもこれらの3つの段階で行われている
と思います
学習者は、ステージ
1で簡単な質問に答えることができます。
ステージ2で
家族について話し、ステージ3で家族について話します。天気について話し
ます。
学習者がこれらの3つ
の言語習得段階を経た場合、意味がないと思います。
ますます多くの語彙を習得し
、言語の構造をより良く理解し、徐々に
これを使用できるようになりますが
、私の意見では、私たちが何を習得できるかでは
なく、何を習得できるかに焦点を当てています。 取得
したものを最終的に使用できるようになる
ので、使用する機会を増やすだけでよい
ので、言語を上達させていくと、
おそらく週に3回、
家庭教師と話します。
田舎に行きますが、
私はすでに
その言語の快適さのレベルを達成したら、
そこにいることを最大限に活用できる
ようになります。そうすれば
、9か月から1年でその快適さを得ることができます。
レベル
アラビア語や中国語の場合は長くなる可能性があり
ますポルトガル語を話す
人がスペイン語を学ぶ場合は短くなる可能性がありますが、それは
私の意見
です。